[Music]
let's go to david in fresno california
what's up david how we doing
uh not as good as i deserve dr john but
i thank you for taking call time to talk
to me you got it man so let's get into
it brother what's up how can i help
uh so nima
together and one from previous marriage
hey hold on one second um i just you cut
out on me so back up and do that one
over again
yeah uh so me and my wife have been
married for three years now um
we have two kids one together and one
for one from her previous relationship
and recently we've been hitting a point
where she seems to be disconnecting from
me
a couple months ago we hit the point
that i felt was financial ruin and the
first time in my adult life of 15 years
was late making payments for the house
for rent and
i felt like everything was crushing
around me
i discovered dave ramsey and the ramsey
network and we discussed about going on
a budget
shortly after going on a budget her
she was at first on board with you know
trying to take control of our money
and then it started to take a turn where
she said that she didn't want to um
have anybody telling her what to do with
her money
and then recently on sunday we were
having a conversation where
she
she told me that
because of my desire to
open and expand our communication
that i'm pushing her away
and i'm at a point where i don't i'm not
sure what to do
how long have you all been together man
uh four years four years
well i i know this much haven't been
married for a lot longer than that you
making this phone call is an act of
bravery and so i applaud you it's hard
um good for you man
often when somebody
when couples have these moments these
breakthrough moments actually let me
back up what happened financially what
pushed you over the over the cliff
um
so she had start she was unemployed for
the last year after my daughter was born
okay um was she unemployed or was she
being a stay-at-home mom
being a stay-at-home mom she started to
do some small businesses because
we were just skimming by on my income
okay
here's the deal
the language we use truly matters deeply
in some of these situations okay
and so there's a difference between
saying
she was just sitting around unemployed
and
she we chose for her to stay at home for
a year with our newborn and some little
in a mix of both does that make sense
one of those has some vitro in it it's
got some character assassination to it
one of them is
we agreed mutually we're gonna scrape
and claw our way by because we think
this is more important in this season
does that make sense
yeah
maybe all weren't that intentional about
it
i wasn't as intentional about it okay
um
it was kind of a
decision that she made and i was told to
that
this is what i'm going to do because i
think that i think that it's best
and from my perspective
i didn't
there was looking at the numbers and the
math of it it was
it was going to be a strong burden and
trying to maintain
the level of life that uh we were both
wanting to live
did you bring in this new life did you
sit down and have that conversation
yes
i'm looking at the numbers and i'm
scared about what's the next year's
going to hold for us
i did okay um
at first it looked like it could be
possible but then i sat down we were
looking at the numbers for the next year
and i said
you know with the added expenses of
diapers clothes that are going to be
coming every two weeks because the
baby's not going to stop growing
i don't see how we're going to be able
to make this work
and at that point she said well then
i'll start making baby clothes i'll
start making bows
and she started that business of hers
online
but she didn't
she didn't put um
she wasn't committed to it
it was a
i'll make it when i feel like it i'm not
gonna go out and really try to
sell these bows and then but i'm just
gonna continue to buy the fabric to make
the clothes that i want to make for my
child so you end up losing money on a
side hustle
yes yeah
um
what is whenever i hear couples
say they can't get on the same page or
somebody calls them in your situation by
the way your situation is very very
common okay
often
there's a backstory in the backstory
usually not always usually is something
like
a woman marries a guy who's a schemer
he's always got a plan if we just do
this then we can get here and if we
can't do that then we're gonna do this
i'm gonna buy this car i'm gonna flip it
for this
there's always a thing going
so then when things get scary we're
broke
like you are as a husband and i've been
there by the way where you're pacing
around at night when your wife and kid
are asleep and you have your hands on
your knees because you can't breathe and
you're like i don't know how we're going
to do this
i've been there that's a scary feeling
am i right
yeah
so then you get on youtube and you find
ramsay solutions which i happen i work
here because i happen to believe it's
the best program that exists for walking
people through how to deal with your
money
um
as a path to freedom
and
then the next morning she wakes up
you're all excited you tell her all
about i got this plan here's what we're
gonna do and your excitement wins the
day for for a few weeks until it the
reality of it wears off
and it's less about the plan and it's
less about unification and it's more
about how it was pitched and
the
it's just a steady it's just another
scheme in a long line of schemes
and so
putting her aside like i want to set her
over for a second because at the end of
the day the only thing on planet earth
you can control is you and that you can
deal with
do you have anger issues do you have
frustration issues i hear in your voice
resentment i hear in your voice
like you're done and i don't know what
to do or i hear you in your voice giving
up and it might be financially it might
just be you're exhausted it might be
you're done with the marriage i don't
know where you are but i can feel it on
you tell me where you are
i'm i'm getting to the point of burnout
okay um
between working full-time
i i was able to get to a point where i
got into a job and pursuing a career
that i love and i'm super passionate
about
and i got excited because i finally went
from working in a job for a job instead
of working in a
vacation as a vocation okay
and what's that job what are you doing
uh so i work in a recruitment team okay
um i do entry level recruitment
specifying in veterans and people with
disabilities love it awesome and that's
that's good work all that's that serves
everybody right that's fantastic and are
you good at it
yeah um i came on i came on the team um
quickly got recognized on a uh national
level with the company cool for my
endeavors in the in the recruitment and
the outreach that we do
creating
community engagement across the entire
nation between the company and
veteran organizations so
but you have another side to you
what is it
it feels that
i feel
that
i have to handle everything why
who told you
to deal with everything
it's it's the actions um i
i come home from work i pick up my
daughter go home from work
and
i i have to is your daughter daycare
uh she stays with family
what does your wife do during the day
she works as a bank teller so she is
working now
yeah she got a job a few months ago
she's working as a bank teller okay um
she
so she gets home
shortly after i do if not maybe just a
little bit before but because of where
she works i pick up my daughter okay um
it's
more
cost-effective because it's on the way
home for me rather than her driving out
of her way absolutely
and those are i've got i've got memories
of picking up my son and taking my son
to school taking my daughter's school
that are that are great memories
um
take me
here
man you and i could unpack this for a
long time i wanted
two things i know for sure one i'm not
getting the full picture here okay i'm
not calling you dishonest there's
something else here that's big
the second thing is it sounds like
one of two things is happening
either when i say something i'm not
getting the full picture
either there's something that you have
done or that makes you un
or
a way you respond or you get angry or
you shut down there's something here
that is contributing to the wedge
and i don't know what it is and we can
that's a whole other phone call okay but
i want you to be honest with yourself
about what you bring to this
the second part of this
is it sounds like two people trying to
do life the way they want it to be done
and without sitting down and mapping out
saying hey who are we going to be
together
and not about money yet not about how
we're going to raise kids yet not about
our
what are we doing like what are we
building together
because we're we're now we're now joined
we're forever in relationship even if we
got divorced tomorrow we are forever in
relationship because we have a child
together
and so who do we want to be what do we
want to become what we want to do
and that's a different conversation that
hey i think i can get us out of debt
because one of those is a scheme the
other one is let's change everything
and getting out of debt is a path to
freedom and peace in our home
that both of you may not have ever known
i don't know your childhoods
and then when you have that conversation
and somebody says i'm out i don't want
to do that
i don't want to dream with you i don't
want to be on the same page parenting
like i'm going to raise my kid how i
want to raise my kid
um i don't want you telling me what to
do with my money i don't care about that
then we're going to look at things like
are there mental health issues are there
um does this person just not want to be
married to you and that's a hard reality
to face but we got to face it otherwise
everyone just gets miserable and we have
to deal with that
um you see where i'm going i'm headed
here it seems like there are some broad
deep
um
or i'll just tell you in my house we
have a money conversation every two
weeks or so but for sure 100 every month
when we get paid
we have a calendar
conversation once a week what does this
week look like what do you need from me
this week how can i honor you this week
um
it's gonna be deposit week so i'm going
to be busier at work it's going to be
not deposit week this is recruiting week
this is the the end of the month so we
got to get our numbers up
like it's it's being a part of one
another's flow of life
and if somebody opts out of that i do
not want to participate in life with you
now we're going to have big hard
conversations about is this marriage
viable
does that make sense
yeah no it does um
have you heard about have you had those
what i hear often is people think
they've had that conversation and they
have not
not to that level okay it's it's been
more of like a
breeze over
and like okay what are we gonna do this
week well we've got a b c and d going
okay well i can take care of this you
can take care of that but
not in the depth of there you go how can
i help support you well and when you
what you just said is beautiful because
that's what's happened to relationships
all across the country especially during
the pandemic
which is couples became great
co-managers of a household
they are not a married couple with
intimacy and connection striving to
create something beautiful in the world
and change family trees
you get the difference there hey i got
this task you get kid i'll get this you
pick up dead on the way home we'll
collapse on the couch watch an episode
will you do bedtime i'll get this i'll
do the diaper and then we repeat
that's a life of co-management it's a
life of misery and at some point one of
y'all will go looking for connections
somewhere else if not both of you
and it sounds like you guys met
y'all been dating for four years
i mean i mean y'all you've known her for
four years you then you got married
relatively quick right and you had a kid
yep okay
and then you got into the pandemic and
then y'all had some major money issues
and so there's been one crisis after
another after another and it's hard to
get your footing back when you're out to
see and you just can't seem to touch and
you're swimming as hard as you can and
you get one toe down in the water i mean
on the ground and then you're you're off
back out to sea again
but i would love for you to spend a few
minutes a couple hours
writing down what you need
not what you're trying to solve not what
you're trying to fix
like dude my name is david and here's
what i need
i miss i miss
i miss my wife
i want to breathe when it comes to money
i want to not worry about money i want
to be good at my job i want to be a
great dad i want to co-parent together
really well
um
and then i want you to take your wife
out to breakfast and say hey we're going
to spend a couple hours and we've got
married quick we've shot out of a cannon
quick you're struggling with things
um
you tell
your desire to be open with her makes
her more uncomfortable for some reason
why do you think that is by the way
does she have no health issues or are
you can you be loud and and kind of this
is my way
but no we both can be loud and this is
my way
she she has been diagnosed with severe
depression
after she was diagnosed um i knew that i
needed help so i sought a counselor and
i've been seeing a counselor for the
past few months because
i'm living with somebody that is not
okay and i need to know how to manage my
feelings in it awesome good for you man
that's fantastic have you noticed some
things working with a counselor that you
need to change
a lot of a lot of what the counselor and
i have been working on is understanding
the functions of the behaviors in our
house not only mine but hers and the
kids
and then once i can start understanding
the function of the behaviors i can
start addressing my reaction
okay you keep doing what your counselor
says but i'm gonna add to that
i want you all to sit down together
would y'all go to breakfast and i want
you to do
[Music]
ask each other are we still both in this
are you are you do you want to be
married to me and this is going to be a
risk-taking vulnerable conversation
because i want to be married to you
and i want to create a pretty amazing
life and depending on how she grew up
and depending on how you grew up you all
may have come from really combustible
homes
where relationships and intimacy and
vulnerability weren't safe weren't good
weren't okay and we're gonna have to
build something new that we've never
even seen before
but are you still in because i am
and from there
draw up on a piece of paper a couple of
columns what are your dreams about where
we're going to live
what do you want to do professionally or
not do professionally
what about when it comes to money let's
dream about a house like if you could
pick any house what would it look like
is it a ranch style house is it a 5 000
square foot like what does it look like
and then what we're gonna do is we're
going to commit together i want
we both want to see these things come to
fruition
what do we have to do and then goes back
to what your accounts are talking about
our behaviors what do we have to change
in our everyday life
to make this stuff happen
and now you are in it together and one
of those tools is
getting out of debt one of those tools
is healing your marriage in your
relationship so here's what i'm gonna do
for you man i'm gonna send you um stay
on the line
and jenna's gonna pick up i'm gonna give
you a year subscription to ramsey plus
all of the financial piece videos
all of the every dollar app that that i
that all of us use around here because
it's the best on the market um to help
keep track of all your spending but and
it helps your wife can buy something
over here and i can buy some over here
and it all dumps into the same app which
is great
um i'm also gonna send you a copy of my
book on your past change your future
it's about saying okay here's what
happened and now what are we gonna do
next
so i'm gonna give you all a bunch of
tools but i want you to sit down and
have a true conversation with your wife
at a retreat not at home not in a fight
this is a beautiful planning opportunity
and a risk because she might say hey i
want out i do not want to be with you
and then you all have to deal with what
comes next after that but i don't think
she's there
start there and let's build something
new let's create a picture of where
we're going to live into and then we're
going to get the tools and i've given
you a bunch
um a couple hundred dollars for the
tools and we're gonna reverse engineer
this thing and we're gonna go make it
work day by day by day
okay
give that a shot and
it may be time for marriage counseling
for both of you she's struggling mental
health you're struggling to love her in
new ways and different ways and to act
differently it may be good for both to
be able to go see somebody together all
right i'm proud of you david
check back in with me and let me know
i'm gonna walk alongside you on this one